life didn't always hurt this much once
upon a time the comma man lived a
simpler life by his own hand but times
are changing the old way of life choking
on the smoke the chimneys the woods
caked in a black suit of the mines coal
field the engine of progress brilliant
ideas like a steam train and it's 16,000
miles of track the world was
transforming before our eyes
accelerating towards something much
greater
there was a native invention we're
clever blokes were thinking up the
unthinkable sending messages across
great distances carrying voices through
wires like magic illuminating the
streets and shops deep into the night
but the dirty secret of it all was the
poor buggers in the factories killing
themselves in the name of the machine
lucky to see their 20th birthday the
factories were no better than a daddy
cry
their deaths are meaningless sacrificed
to line the pockets of the wealth I've
seen too many starving families begging
for scraps father rich stuff their faces
too many women dropping their knickers
for a shilling or the upper class where
a king's ransom people did what they
needed to survive it brings us back to
me where the fun was just freaking
the working class have been exploited
long enough the city needed a change but
I can do it long
you could call us organized eliminating
our rifles reclaiming our glorious
Empire one borough at a time our best
shot popping round 40 taking a stroll in
the midnight air of jolly old London
town and with our growing influence we
turned all sides to Creighton justices
the train baron a man who put hundreds
on the street because they stood in the
path of his railway a man who stole what
he wanted from those who had nothing but
there was one thing he would never
receive mercy
you
well then now you know what's required
to join the rocks are you in army
welcome to the family Assassin's Creed
syndicate
you